now what's bizarre in this world of
left-wing censorship is that what is not
censored what is not banned
becomes mandatory there's a clip that's
resurfaced of the uh Senate candidate
the Democrat Senate nominee in
Pennsylvania John fetterman who was
dressed up in a bizarre rainbow cape and
hat looking
well pretty much as weird as he always
does but in a slightly different way
John fetterman was interviewed last year
by some LGBT LMNOP activist on whether
or not he believes that LGBT education
grooming should be mandatory in schools
here's what he says now with the uh
especially education which is what our
Focus here at Power rainbows is uh would
you support the Department of Education
making it mandatory in all schools for
lgbtq education
I'm sorry I didn't hear the last part
would you make it uh would you be
supportive of legislation that makes it
mandatory for lgbtq education in our
schools for History Literature science
and so on I I I'm for as many
perspectives and and letting everybody
be included in because we're all part of
America and we all have history and that
should be a part of of American History
because you are a part of America in
these communities you know so
so he's trying to avoid giving a direct
answer to the question but but in trying
to avoid it he does give a direct answer
he's saying I want everything to be
included everything including
apparently LGBT education I don't know
what LGBT education is by the way
what does he mean do you think LGBT
education should be mandatory in schools
what teaching them how to do the stuff
teaching them what what is LGB LGBT
education
sounds like grooming to me I know that
word is being bandied about a lot but if
you're if you're teaching someone the
ins and outs as it were of LGBT then
isn't that grooming isn't that what the
conservatives are accusing the libs of
doing the libs are basically admitting
it right there
and of course John fetterman doesn't
want every perspective included he
doesn't think the Bible should be taught
in schools the most the the fundamental
text of Western Civilization I Promise
You John fetterman doesn't think that
should be taught in schools but gender
queer by Maya kababi should be LGBT
pornography like genderqueer I guess
that should be taught in schools that
should be mandatory the Bible that's got
to be banned speaking of LGBT activism
by the way
the most delightful hilarious clip of
the weekend comes by way of the LGBT
community and LGBT issues which is Joe
Biden
apparently blaming Elton John for AIDS
by the way
it's all his fault that we're spending
six billion dollars in taxpayer money
this month to help aides fight HIV AIDS
you could see Elton John he's like is
what is this man
is he blaming me for AIDS and then
blaming me for spending taxpayer money
on AIDS and then and Biden finally
finishes Elton John's looking so puzzled
and then Elton John goes he has no idea
what he's saying I'll just smile and he
kind of gives a little smile and gives
some Applause I assume what Joe Biden is
trying to insinuate here is that Elton
John lobbied for this government
spending on AIDS
but the way it comes out is not that's
not how it sounds we got to blame this
guy this guy he man you know this guy
come on Jack you know this guy probably
him and Corn Pop went down to a few too
many bath houses now we got to spend a
gazillion dollars of your money on AIDS
come on give a round of applause for
Elton John it's like what
what the heck man that's that's that's
his homophobic
as it possibly gets Nancy Pelosi was
just booed
at a music festival in New York City
of the house
this is the global citizen Festival in
New York City you would imagine that
these people are overwhelmingly Libs and
then there's Nancy Pelosi up there
speaking and she's getting booed and
this fight you hear that one guy in the
back goes why is everybody booing
I don't know the clip that's gone viral
actually doesn't give a ton of context
into specifically what Nancy Pelosi is
talking about but here's why she might
be being booed
because everything that the Democrats
have touched has turned to Ash the
economy foreign policy education
immigration and everything in the middle
it's all Fallen apart this is why the
Democrats are underwater on every single
public policy issue this is why the
Democrats are running way way behind
when you look at the polls for the
midterm elections
so I'm frankly I'm not really surprised
that Nancy Pelosi is getting booed in
New York City
New Yorkers
especially the ones that are kind of you
know in the the rich parts of town who
go to all the fancy liberal soirees they
can be taken with liberal Flights of
Fancy but they they don't like getting
mugged
they don't like dirty streets they don't
like bums and criminals running around
everywhere
they don't like when the economy is
tanking
they don't like stupid foreign policy
that's causing huge disruptions to the
energy industry and to the stock market
and to end everything they don't like
bad government okay
and so how are the Democrats going to
win in this kind of an environment the
only thing they can do
is threaten violence
this is this is why to get back to the
very top of the show this is why Joe
Biden is sicking his thugs his Jack
booted thugs on ordinary nice polite
pro-life activists this is why Joe Biden
is hiring 87 000 IRS agents and giving
some of them guns to go after you
this is why Joe Biden is letting his
criminals off the hook the BLM criminals
and the antifa criminals he's letting
them off the hook he's encouraging them
to terrorize you
and why he is throwing you in prison
it's why he's taking the the midwestern
grandmothers who show up to the Capitol
Rotunda and get a little excitable on
January 6th he's throwing them in
solitary confinement but he's letting
the BLM Thugs who kill people off the
hook
because the only way
that an unpopular liberal agenda can
maintain its political power
is through coercion and through force
and through the threat of violence I'm
so glad you like that clip now like
subscribe Ring Ding Dong get the
notifications we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]